I the frame is one of the better
solution for those who require reading
glasses when they reach me th is good
for reading as well as even for
progressive error who need a replacement
or substitute that they can have a wider
vision feel for the close-up or so what
I need is freaked out forfar and flip up
for really
we have one true by a period to do some
research on our flip up earlier
prototypes we encounter some
difficulties in terms of the scratches
between the top by and the frame front
and also the instability of the frame
front that hook onto the top bar so this
took us quite a period until we succeed
by now design is not just about
aesthetic we notice that the allowable
design in terms of products the sudden
lacking in good functionality
Timbo is definitely very important we
bring in a team of our own design
personnel as well as the mechanical
engineers we need to get a two-team to
cooperate to make sure that the design
and the functions are in place the
president design award is a good
platform for adding the designers to
gather together to know each other to
learn from each other we get inspired
and also to understand that a good
design can add value to your products
I think for the young aspiring designer
is important for them to understand that
it's a long challenging road they're
going to be very resilient and have the
determination to walk that extra mile to
see success
this is the eyelid flip design of the
year
Oh